we're in a culture that's a
billion-dollar business but we create
millionaires well you start standing by
your word you'll be able to build more
relationships and resources you know
what if you're gonna get in a cell you
got to be prepared you got to do
something you get into a room you gotta
take advantage of network having an open
conversation sometimes you got to look
in like pop all you want to go I love to
win the people that love to win they're
gonna be successful probably one of the
first in only to play in the NBA he's an
American rapper actor entrepreneur and
former basketball player he's a founder
and CEO of P Miller enterprises a
conglomerate company in 2013 Forbes
estimated his net worth to be 350
million dollars he's master p and here
is my take on his top ten rules for
success
we're in a culture that's a
billion-dollar business but we create
millionaires I talk to a lot of guys
that I know that got a lot of big
contracts in the financial advisors
running everything and it's like when
basketball over so you can't play
basketball anymore you haven't put
anything into learning financial
literacy where do you go from that you
go back to the hood they take everything
they steal everything that you have
we're not thinking ownership you got
somebody writing your checks even though
there's good financial advisors out
there but the most of them most of them
and at the end of these guys careers
there's no is the same story what
happened to my money I come from
independence I come from owning product
that's what that's the way I was able to
be who I am and as I grow and mature you
know I'm thinking like whatever LeBron
owned the Cavs how much money he would
be making on Nike you know it's good
Nike gave him a billion-dollar shoe did
a lifetime deal but how much money are
they gonna make off him what happens
when we own actually own the product
when you look at all the all of all the
big brands from Apple TV 2 apple music
you know these guys are taking over the
industry and we got to go to them to
sell them our products and to get a
small piece but we are not creating
brands oh no and I think that's where I
plan to change the game you know I
wanted to be more of us more minorities
having an opportunity to cash out on
what we do every day if you a
businessman an entrepreneur you got to
find a problem so I found a problem
record stores are closing but video game
stores are opening that and that's when
it hit to me I'm like I need to be in a
video game business I put my life my
passion and saying what I did into the
music I put into the video game and
I'm mostly like probably the only person
that looked like me come from our
culture that's a part of this in Silicon
Valley just like she was saying when you
give somebody your word your word is so
important once I gave her my word I had
to come you were not I've got the
million other things I got to do is say
well I gave my word and that's gonna go
a long way with you in business once you
give somebody your word it's good to get
it in right everything that you need to
get done but when you give somebody your
word you gotta stand by because when you
start standing by your word you'll be
able to build more relationships and
resources you know what if you're gonna
get in the stuff you got to be prepared
you got to do something big you know and
you gotta you gotta you know I feel like
this power record with me in lo Wang
it's definitely a statement record but
it's just real this time it I know I
mean I tell you all the time man on my
time we won't go as soon absolutely so
how the Brian James a 1l feel when
you're in the gym you got to go practice
work on your jump shot
work on your game I feel like or does
not need to spend that time in the
studio then just Paul in order my whole
life is about helping the kid helping
other kids you know linens look at my
life do a boot print you know you can't
just make any music in a music business
I want to show people that you got a you
gotta have a couple of things long cuz
when that when that things and ran out
something else might open up you know
the film the TV open up for me or the
clothing you know the music business is
not the same yeah so it's like like you
say it about the marketing is about the
endorsement deals so you got to get
hiding something to get though you did
so you know I think in this game 9 what
I don't know how to do best is about
being independent you know so if you're
independent you could make moves the way
you want to make it you're gonna be
successful now down the line you meet
somebody you might see them again and
they gonna remember you you build those
relationships I did the same thing with
all we Warren Buffett didn't know he was
Warren Buffett
you guys you know I'm sitting in the
room with Donald Trump Robert Kiyosaki
and I'm thinking these are the guys you
know and he told me said man look his
old guy over here he makes a million
dollars he's touching the computer and
I've been holding this guy the whole
time you know and I'm like wow you never
know who you might be sitting next to
who you might meet so you got when you
get into a room you got to take
advantage of network having an open
conversation meet somebody telling you
your name telling them where you from
telling of what business you in you know
tell them whatever whatever you involved
in because that person might know
somebody say hey you know you into okay
I could hook you up with them like oh
okay yeah this is my guy from over here
that's what building relationships is
about in network and that's the first
part of business being entrepreneur
because you might not have the money to
start the business even though you
entrepreneur you got the idea that's how
people say they started a business with
no money they had the idea but then they
went to somebody and network with the
person that had the money right now and
through the power the internet right now
should have to sit back and wait it's
about creating opportunity don't wait
for something right now the Internet is
so strong with me you look at it it's
all chucks a look at a guy like soldier
boy just came on the Internet so you've
got sit back wait even though people
laughing so the old man is built
yourself or whatever but this guy create
is not happening but you like Chuck same
he also had to go sell out to take it to
a big picture now my thing is sometimes
you got to look at and like pop all you
want to go you might think it's
independence I thought that this was a
happening I was able to open up the
creek and still be able to empower our
own people in the community so I just
think that we have to figure out how far
we want to go in before that that they
are turned down a million dollar deal
with Jimmy I mean Jimmy Iovine offered
me a million dollars and I'm in the
project I had like 500 I was in my
pocket okay so I went to see him and my
brother was with my brother see it was
like man take the million now they're
gonna be rich and go take over the
project I said nah ain't taking over
don't present okay when I get this baby
now I'm going I'm out of this I don't
even want to see no more president I
need to be gone so I sit in that office
I had to check but I read the paperwork
so orders that's watching this you need
to read the paperwork by me going to
college outlook I was like to my mind
I'm thinking this is a Michael Jordan
tickets Michael Jordan got a million
dollars from Nike
he would have been a billionaire people
don't know that but they gave him maybe
like 3% a 5% of something like that so I
was like I can't do this deal because I
won't own my name no more none of this
stuff so I told I say I said mr. bean
I'm gonna get some lunch I'll be back so
he was like man if you don't come back
you would never get a deal in this town
I get back on the plane I'm on Southwest
start eating them peanuts I start
thinking about that million dollar make
the people you wanting more peanuts me
my brother man we bout to fight he's
right it was like go man why would you
not take the million dollars knowing
that we don't have no money so how much
money you got - I got 500
he said you got 500 out he turned out
million as I say but before we start
shipping on each other if that white man
offered me a million now how much you
think I'm worth that'd be worth 10 15 20
something you know that's when he left
me alone it was a long ride back to New
Orleans but you know but that's some
time you gotta take chances on yourself
I think you know a lot of people they
say the hustles they said it from the
streets but why somebody else putting
your music on if you really on the
street I'm these records I'm hands yeah
how you trapping and how you doing all
right you know you should be input your
own musica right you don't need nobody
but your musica
right nothing we was out there if we
change our life but we put our own
musica right we did our own thing I like
to win I love to win
the people that love to win they're
gonna be successful but this okay losing
some time you might not win all the time
because you always say tomorrow I loves
today but tomorrow I'm gonna make up for
it so be prepared to take losses in
business being entrepreneurs so that's
the thing about it but that one win take
away all the pain if you want to put
north and you own your own business and
you run your business well I'm probably
the first hip-hop artists to make a
movie independent film I'm probably the
first hip-hop artists to do a sports
agency I'm probably the one of the first
hip-hop artists that do clothing
probably one of the first and only to
play in the NBA probably one of the
first and only to make an 80/20 deal
distribution deal I mean I could go on
and on then but it's like you know I
mean so many doors and opened up fire
people
and I'm just glad to be a part of that
that history thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
mystery MediaCorp asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know which of Master
P's top ten rules hit you the hardest
and why leave it in the comments I will
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon
[Music]
the most important work ever if you have
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]